as the horror genre's reigning final
girl lori strode played by jamie lee
curtis exceeds her reputation in the
2018 sequel halloween despite the
self-inflicted isolation of her
militaristic lifestyle and the resulting
strained relationships with her family
strode is ready for the inevitable
return of michael myers halloween is the
first installment in a trilogy directed
by david gordon green the films are
direct sequels to the original 1978 film
of the same name directed by john
carpenter the film became the highest
grossing entry in the halloween
franchise making over 250 million
dollars worldwide according to
entertainment weekly co-writer danny
mcbride said they were eager to shoot a
sequel but wanted to make sure audiences
were on board first halloween is
certified fresh on rotten tomatoes with
many critics and fans agreeing that it's
a welcome change for the franchise now
the much anticipated sequel halloween
kills is officially on the horizon and
here's everything we know about the film
so far the initial release date of
halloween kills was october 16 2020 but
a july 2020 statement from green and
carpenter revealed that the film was
delayed because of the pandemic not
dissimilar to many other films that were
scheduled to be released in 2020. if we
release it in october of this year as
planned we have to face the reality that
the film would be consumed in a
compromised theatrical experience after
weighing our options we have chosen to
push the film's theatrical release by
one year now nearly one year later
halloween kills is scheduled to premiere
at the 17th venice international film
festival on september 8th it'll be
hitting u.s theaters on october 15th
additionally the release date for
halloween ends is set for october 14th
2022 meaning we shouldn't have to endure
such a brutal wait time before seeing
the trilogy's final entry of course
jamie lee curtis will be reprising her
iconic role as lori strode the tormented
babysitter turned fighter the other
strode women will be returning as well
judy greer is back as laurie's estranged
daughter karen and andy matichak is back
as karen's daughter allison additionally
michael myers will be portrayed by nick
castle and james jude courtney again
will patton and jabril natambu will also
be reprising their roles from the
previous film while halloween kills is
naturally pulling from characters
introduced in the 2018 film it's also
bringing back characters from the 1978
version the young children laurie
babysat in the original are all grown up
now tommy doyle will be portrayed by
anthony michael hall while kyle richards
is reprising her role as lindsay wallace
nancy stevens is reprising her role as
marion chambers a retired nurse charles
ciphers is reprising his role as lee
bracket the former haddenfield sheriff
whose daughter was killed by myers in an
interview with empire green and mcbride
explained that halloween kills picks up
directly where the previous film ended
however while the first film focused on
lori's life 40 years after surviving a
brutal killing spree green said this is
more about the unraveling of a community
into chaos the 2018 film ends with
michael myers trapped and left for dead
in lori's flame engulfed home but as
fans know the captain kirk masked killer
doesn't go down easily or at all the
halloween kills trailer shows myers
walking out to the front door and
attacking the firefighters before
resuming his reign of terror on the
small midwestern town as myers leaves a
trail of bodies leading to his childhood
home where it all began the haddenfield
residents rallied together to hunt down
the obsessive killer lori leaves the
hospital where she's recovering from a
stab wound and makes a bold declaration
evil
dies
tonight mcbride explained to empire
events in the film bring together a lot
of characters who were in the 1978 film
who we didn't see last time they gather
to try once and for all to take down
michael to stop this madman it's
unlikely that myers will be defeated in
halloween kills especially considering
that there's one more film to come in
the trilogy but anything's possible
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one